Okay.
I want today to talk about,
um,
two very well known,
crises.
I in the third republic,
uh,
one is the Buddha on j affair,
and the second is the more well known,
uh,
the Dreyfus affair.
Um,
and I guess what makes the drivers a fair bit more poignant is that I is that
Alfred Dreyfus,
his granddaughter,
I died at Auschwitz in 1944 I think.
So,
um,
and the context for this is to,
most of the time I'm going to talk with a on j affair and,
uh,
and in a way that sets up the Dreyfus affair because the Dreyfus affair is more
well known,
but,
uh,
I agree with interpretation of used the blue,
the Honcho Fair bluejay affair as,
uh,
the emergence of a,
the far right,
uh,
in France,
events that parallel,
for example,
the rise of,
of uh,
uh,
the far right in,
in Austria and in other places as well.
And particularly this was a propaganda campaign.
The antisemitism,
uh,
and the sort of street thug tactics are rather similar to,
to movements that we would become all too familiar with.
Uh,
and I personally,
of course,
but in the 1920s,
in 1930.
So that's what I want to talk about today.
And the background of this is of course,
the rise of antisemitism,
uh,
workable one unleashed the demons of the 20th century to a great extent.
There's no question about that.
Uh,
for an out of Hitler.
It,
it transformed it I,
his Auntie,
uh,
anti socialism and subsequent anti-communism,
into a frenzy,
but it added that dimension that was the most pernicious aspect of,
uh,
his horrible existence,
which was a antisemitism,
but antisemitism was already out there.
Uh,
and,
uh,
at Karl Luber,
who was the mayor of Vienna,
said,
I decide who's a Jew.
A and the old liberal,
uh,
old liberal,
a vns or have disappeared in the surf frenzy of antisemitism.
Well,
antisemitism,
it was characterized.
Uh,
uh,
unfortunately the,
many centuries,
uh,
in Europe,
and certainly the third republic did not invent antisemitism in France either.
There were,
uh,
riots against Jews after 1848.
There were,
uh,
one of the members of the committee of public safety in the French Revolution
who's from Alsace,
uh,
where there were lots of Jews,
was extraordinarily antisemitic.
Uh,
and all of this,
this is a sadly,
uh,
sadly no,
but certainly the political dimensions of antisemitism in the eighties and
nineties,
uh,
help explain the intensity of these two big affairs.
And for the Dreyfus affair,
it was so important and so wrenching or that simply where people simply refer to
it as la fare,
the affair because it was so,
it preoccupied,
uh,
he preoccupied,
a dinner table discussions and brawls,
uh,
political,
newspapers and everything else for a very long time.
Now,
in addition to,
um,
the sort of growth of antisemitism,
uh,
continued growth in France and other places,
the other part of the context that needs to be briefly explained,
it has two dimensions.
First,
uh,
there was the question of revenge,
of,
of vengeance,
of the recapture of,
of,
um,
of Alsace,
uh,
and the parts of Lohan that had been so rudely a snatch to way.
Um,
it's possible to exaggerate.
Of course,
the impact is one of my former students,
uh,
Rachel crestal has argued,
of revolt,
Angie's Ma revenge,
uh,
thinking,
on French political life,
uh,
in,
the seventh and the 1870s and eighties,
eighties.
Uh,
but by the end of the 1880s,
it's still is an important part in political thinking.
And that the and brutal on Jay's campaign,
uh,
reflected that fact.
And the second is that a,
the second of aspect of background is the perceived weakness of the Republican
government,
uh,
in that,
in order to protect France against Caesar Rhythm,
which I've explained before,
was the fear of,
you know,
who knows another Napoleon or some sort of strong leader,
a riding a horse and,
and,
uh,
starting wars,
um,
or repressing a,
their own people rather like a Napoleon.
The third had done,
uh,
they create a constitutional framework that,
invest power in the Chamber of deputies basically.
And the,
and the Shama did deputy is,
uh,
a political club,
which I've said before,
and the same members are often return to year after year.
The same.
Bribes are given big costs of wine or barrels of wine or put up a,
uh,
near,
a voting booth and,
and everything,
uh,
proceeds,
at least this is the popular in the popular imagination,
uh,
as,
a political club of swinging door,
uh,
ministries.
And certainly,
um,
you know,
if you look at just take 1889 to 1893,
and,
you know,
not responsible for this because I mean basically who cares,
but,
uh,
about the,
these details,
but they're 546 different sessions between 1889 in 1893,
873 bills introduced I between 93 98 or 633 sessions with 1,112 bills with the
government,
uh,
presenting on its own,
well over 2000.
But in fact,
if you look at the accomplishments besides providing,
you know,
a certain stability,
the accomplishments seem to be rather pale when,
ah,
you've got people both on the left and the right thing saying that the big issue
is over there and over there is to,
uh,
in the east of what had been France that is Alsace.
Uh,
and,
uh,
Lauren,
I and Clay's each bill,
we had to be discussed by a whole commission of Deputies and then went on and
on,
uh,
commissions or become sort of mini ministries.
Uh,
the,
the perception is that,
that,
that this is an impotent system.
It's an empathy system that's condemned France to be less than virile.
And remember,
this is the time when the population,
people are becoming very afraid of the fact that the population is not
reproducing itself.
Uh,
so,
uh,
this is one of,
of the big,
um,
images of simply,
uh,
eh,
instability.
Uh,
and it's the same people.
It's the same,
uh,
ministries that are reconstituted rather like Italian politics.
And it's as much of the,
of the,
of the pre,
the post World War II era.
There were 180 ministries between 1870,
uh,
and 1940.
Um,
and,
uh,
the average tenure is about three years.
But that,
but that's not really not a,
it's not a month,
not much,
but yet,
I mean,
this is to exaggerate because the third republic does provide a,
uh,
you know,
a stability for all of these great affairs.
The Republic survives these,
these two big affairs.
The Republic raises enough money to pay off the indemnity,
uh,
to the newly formed German empire.
Um,
but it is,
people react as to what they're thinking and not necessarily,
uh,
the reality that people are looking,
who are looking at this a,
a deeper.
So that's the,
the Moodle on j affair or the crisis,
uh,
is more,
let's call it the bull and a crisis.
And the Dreyfus affair is better,
is more significant.
Uh,
then the events which are,
um,
are,
are interesting,
uh,
in their own way.
Uh,
and of course,
the other background,
as I said the other day,
or the other context is,
is are these political crises of corruption,
uh,
which,
you know,
in our country,
we should,
we're all too familiar with as well.
Uh,
the Panama crisis and the sale of,
of,
um,
uh,
lesion on donor by,
the presence,
a son in law,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
But this kind of frustration then builds up an anti parliamentarian,
uh,
movement,
in France,
uh,
and the temptation of trying to find a strong man who will right this wrong and
who we'll reattach the right arm of France,
Alsace and Lorraine to,
uh,
to France.
Um,
the general,
uh,
a CRT whom you've read about it as you would a fairy he wrote in 1885.
That's a general impression is that the republic is the end of its rope.
Next year we will have revolutionary excesses again,
and then a violent reaction.
What will come out of this?
Surely some sort of dictatorship.
Uh,
the feeling,
uh,
that,
the government was powerless.
Now,
a guy called the Paul,
uh,
the hoe and add a creates in May of 1882,
the league of the Patriots,
he called himself a simple bell ringer,
uh,
for this anti parliamentary ultra nationalistic a of movement.
And it quickly has 182,000 members,
which is a phenomenal amount.
Uh,
and it,
there's great echoes of,
of,
of aggressive patriotism,
uh,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
And with this began,
uh,
the,
the rapidly rising career of general,
uh,
Josh,
Boulogne Jay who was born in 1837,
this son of a farmer,
uh,
and a Welsh,
a mother,
uh,
he was,
he had fought in four campaigns.
He was wounded six times.
Uh,
he was lucky,
uh,
and that he wasn't killed.
Um,
he was wounded at the,
during the Paris commune,
but before the great reprisals took place.
So he wasn't identified with the massacre of ordinary people.
I hit the campaign's,
he'd fought in Africa,
he'd fought in Italy,
and he'd fought in,
uh,
in Vietnam or what they called in those days.
Uh,
Indochina,
he was a brave,
heroic figure.
Uh,
he cut a mean,
uh,
look on a,
on a or a,
an image on a horse.
He was a good a horseman.
He wasn't very bright,
but that never,
uh,
heard him,
at all.
Uh,
he,
uh,
received one promotion after another.
He's the head of a whole military division at the age of 48,
which is extremely young.
Uh,
but he had lots of energy.
But as I said,
not many brains and no tape,
particular talent for organization,
but he fit the image of what many people in France who were fed up with
republic,
uh,
believed that they,
the,
the France needed.
He was sent to the u s that is this place,
uh,
at Yorktown.
I,
in order to represent France at the centennial of,
uh,
of essentially the,
the British is surrender,
uh,
in,
the American,
uh,
revolution I,
and he costs a stir to by refusing to leave the ship,
uh,
on which he'd arrived in America until they took down the German flags that were
also being flown at the same time.
And it,
and it is precisely the eighties when the mass press is developing in,
in France.
And so these are just fabulous grow teeth,
big headlines in the newspaper.
So it becomes clear to the shoe shoe.
He becomes kind of the darling of a press,
which is dominated by,
has always in France by the right wing press because of,
of a,
a big money was,
it was the case traditionally United States and other countries,
uh,
as well.
Um,
but he's on good terms with come on soul who was,
you know,
the Republican par excellence,
both had graduated from the same high school,
or at least say,
uh,
in,
not on the edge of,
of Normandy.
Uh,
I mean,
they had to have Brittany I,
he shared,
come on sows residual,
uh,
or at least the inherent anticlerical wisdom.
Uh,
and that's something he would temper later as he's going after a right wing
support.
He became the director of the infantry at the war office.
Um,
and,
uh,
his superiors noted that he had a taste for clumsy,
intrigued I,
and complained about the civilians or the [inaudible] as they were called the
Peking.
Uh,
people to civilians and they were treated with contempt to buy,
uh,
but by the military.
And of course,
the role of the French army really all the way through,
you know,
the,
uh,
to the Algerian war has been this tension between the officer corps very,
very right wing and the civilian population.
Thus the attempts to kill the gall himself.
Uh,
and the time of,
of the Algerian,
uh,
situation.
And so he,
um,
you know,
as an operator and he was that,
uh,
he,
um,
he took every possible opportunity to be seen in front of his troops.
Uh,
he,
uh,
he welcomed recruits with military,
music as well as with [inaudible].
It was his idea to paint,
to paint all the century boxes,
red,
white,
and blue.
Uh,
and,
um,
he,
uh,
at one point I had been insulted by somebody,
then chamber of Deputies and he fights a dual,
uh,
if people fought a duel is a lot then,
and his,
his,
uh,
adoring public for,
gave him for the fact that it's gone.
Actually it didn't go off and that nobody was hurt in 1886 during the strike of
the cause.
Vila uh,
he did a very clever thing.
I,
in one of those soundbites before there were sound bites,
somebody said,
what do you think about the strike in the cause?
Vila of the miners in the Cassville.
And he replied,
at this very moment,
French soldiers are sharing their relations with a striking workers.
It was perfect.
And so he gets the support,
at least in the early days of many workers who could imagine a kind of
Napoleonic figure who can at least talk a good game about caring of caring about
them,
even though he really,
uh,
didn't it all on the 14th of July,
1886,
all eyes are on him and they start writing songs about him.
Our brave general boot on Jay who will bring back Alsace.
And Lauren,
uh,
he is co called general victory.
Uh,
a fairly soon one of the lines goes,
look at him over there.
He's smiling at us as he passes us by.
Uh,
he has just brought us back in El Sauce.
Um,
and so the German situation,
tensions with the German Empire,
uh,
Eh,
increase his popularity,
uh,
Bismarck himself.
That is Otto von Bismarck,
the,
uh,
the Kg,
chancellor a of the second hike,
uh,
was aware of him,
and he,
uh,
uses a boodle and Jay's popularity for his own internal benefit,
in,
uh,
in Germany saying when France has any reason to believe that,
that she is stronger than we are on that day.
I believe that war is certain.
And one of the few ways of,
of that the Reichstag had and trying to rein in the,
uh,
the Kaiser arguably was attempting to,
to,
uh,
I have some control of our military budget.
So,
so,
uh,
Biz Biz mark uses a him very,
effectively,
and then there's a spy crisis,
a this terribly uninteresting,
uh,
and,
um,
uh,
it helps a [inaudible].
So this begins to scare people.
And as you would a gravy now,
whose son was the one implicated in the sale of a Alaysia on donor that says
that he's got to go,
but what do you do with them?
Uh,
you can't really make him a martyr.
if you make him a martyr,
uh,
then it looks like,
he,
um,
uh,
you know,
who knows,
maybe there'll be some sort of a Todd attempt.
Um,
he,
he is not allowed to run for office because he's still in the army,
but he's as a write in candidate,
he gets something that he gets 39,000 votes in,
which is a,
you know,
a large amount.
And so,
uh,
the government says let's get rid of them before the next July 14th before,
so he can't ride his horse down.
The Sean sleazy again.
Uh,
and so they send him to decide to senator into Claremont,
Claremont fit home,
uh,
in Ovadia.
Uh,
and he's supposed to leave from the Godell y'all on the train,
uh,
on the 8th of July.
And huge crowds start singing to the lycee that has seized power and they block
the tracks is the first case that I know of,
uh,
of people actually physically blocking railroad tracks as a,
as a sign of,
of,
um,
uh,
political protests.
And they're singing in Moussa.
Yes.
Uh,
also,
which is,
you know,
one thing is the song of the French revolution,
but they're there,
you have this sort of mixed because you've got this old server Jacabao uh,
we'll take what we want attitude,
uh,
mixing with this sort of anti Republican,
right.
And Munos j seems like somebody who could please everybody in the early days he
gets when he was soon be a real candidate.
He gets votes from the left while he's getting money.
Lots of it from the far right.
And among all from monarchists who somehow see him as a way of bringing back
the,
the monarchy.
There's this very wealthy,
a monarchist Dutches from originally the family from [inaudible] and the gap,
uh,
in,
you know,
the south of France and,
uh,
and she gives him lots of big bucks and Clayman.
So dumps him as a friend saying that General Boulogne Jay's popularity has come
too soon for one who likes noise.
So very much.
Um,
and then this,
this,
this incident,
they keep referring to this crisis,
the scandal of,
of gravy.
A son in law begins to,
um,
uh,
a big begins to come along.
Uh,
and there are demonstrations against the republics,
very existence.
Uh,
the republic,
again,
that cannot take back Alsace.
So ran,
and it seems as rampant by this sort of,
uh,
a pool party,
this sort of corruption,
corrupt politics,
uh,
here and there.
Um,
and,
um,
uh,
who comes along to be president of France,
but study come,
no,
the same one who was going to be assassinated,
uh,
in,
1894,
as you've already heard.
And,
and when he's elected,
there was a famous line went around,
somebody said of the deputy,
you know,
the presidents elected by the deputies,
not by the French population.
And someone says,
oh,
come on.
So,
um,
who should we vote for you,
asha,
you know,
who should we vote for me?
He says,
vote for the stupidest volfer study,
Camo,
and arguably study Commonweal was the stupidest.
Uh,
and so he,
uh,
he becomes a president of,
of,
of France OLED.
Any further comments?
Go?
Anyway,
the contrast,
uh,
between a boot on Jay and between,
and this sort of impotent a republic become a more and more marked.
Now I'm one thing leads to another and a chips are wine tells a story,
but it comes down to the fact that he's sitting in a restaurant in Paris,
uh,
in 1889.
He's now no longer a ineligible to be a candidate,
and he's elected to the Chamber of Deputies and he's dining in a restaurant near
the Church of the Madeleine.
When could imagine it being Maxine's favorite,
uh,
a famous restaurant there.
Uh,
and there's a crowds of people in the streets.
And this particular restaurant is not far from the Chamber of Deputies,
is right across the river,
basically from the Chamber of Deputies.
Um,
and he,
um,
he hears the crowd shouting for him to take action,
uh,
to go out and greet his adores.
And then who knows,
as the rightest would try to do.
And on February 6th,
1934 to row across the river and to end this impotent republic,
but he just sits there and he sits there on four on false,
on Walsh called ma'am.
And he sits there and he finishes his elaborate meal.
I would have been there,
not with him,
I wouldn't have died with him,
but I would have finished every plate myself,
uh,
in every glass of wine as well.
And then he goes upstairs with his mistress,
a to a nearby hotel.
And the opportunity I is,
is,
uh,
is past.
And while he hesitates,
so someone wants,
wrote his enemies,
uh,
do not,
they eliminate the electoral a procedure that it allowed him to be,
uh,
to be elected.
Um,
he is worried that they're going to arrest him.
And so he goes off to brew,
sell.
He goes off to,
uh,
to Belgium and this makes them seem a little less dashing and a little less
brave as he scurries across the frontier.
Um,
and um,
there's a committee working for him.
I in France,
but he stays there.
And in the end,
what he does is,
um,
he was very devoted to his ministers for all these years.
I,
and she becomes ill in 1891 and she dies after a long,
horrible illness and we don't,
Jay knows,
couple hours in Anahata,
uh,
on the 30th of September,
1891,
he went alone to her grave and blew his brains out.
And that was the end of boot on Jay the republic,
or merged a strengthened by this crisis.
But that's only one thing that's important about it.
What's more important about it is what was happening to the right in this
context.
And what does this have to tell us about mass politics?
What it has to tell us is that it's the mass politics.
Uh,
I've that Moodle and Jay and this crisis is one of the great examples of this
new political world,
uh,
that you could find.
Uh,
I had one of my TA's years ago whose dissertation I directed,
uh,
it's a passive,
he,
Latanya,
long,
long time ago,
uh,
he went offers thesis,
which became a very interesting book.
And I was interested in this very a question.
And so I draw on,
on,
on some of of his findings that I just discussed with him.
Uh,
uh,
very often,
what he did,
incidentally,
this is what one does with some dissertations.
He went off and he looked at four different parts of France and one was the
mile.
That is the departments of the last one was the easier it would just go nobles
department.
One is the jazz famous for his flog raw,
uh,
and as Armagnac to at least in part.
Uh,
and uh,
the other was the on that which is a Norman Department,
uh,
in the west,
the capital of which is out on song.
And what he was more interested in is how the message got out to very ordinary
people living in those places.
How do they know about boot on j and what,
and this is part of mass politics.
One of the ways that people for centuries had learned how to read or not if they
didn't even know how to read,
but how to,
to imagine a religious and political and military events was in reading.
Uh,
the equivalent,
and I'm not dissing them by calling them comic strips,
but their format was rather like that they were called the Imago Dei p novel.
There are images that were cranked out that were produced in the town of AP Nol
in the east of France in the voltage that would describe,
uh,
or show you pictures of,
of saints.
I would show you pictures of generals.
It would show you Napoleon,
it would show you all sorts of things.
And these are peddled to villages,
uh,
by these [inaudible].
They're called in French by these peddlers who carry these huge leather sacks
that looked like medicine balls.
But there were about three times bigger than that.
And when the,
in a lot of them were from the [inaudible],
from the area of to lose,
a lot of them are from the [inaudible] that is in the,
in the mountains of,
of the massive songs hall.
And a lot of them above all were from the mountains of the Alps near Grenoble.
And these people had their whole credit networks established where they could
get credit to get to their next stops all the way through.
France is a tremendously interesting phenomenon.
And they followed this same routes year after year.
They were known,
anticipated.
They sold pins,
a,
they sold pens,
they sold images of the Virgin Mary.
They showed images of,
of sold images of,
of Sasa Bassiana though you wouldn't get away with selling that in parts of
France.
Uh,
they sold cups,
anything that they could carry and they could sell.
And they sold these images of,
of,
uh,
of the became a political life.
And so butoh and Jay is plugged into this or popular library,
if you will,
at a time when most people could now read,
uh,
the kinds of pamphlets and images of him arrive with these peddlers carrying
this stuff on their backs.
These are hardy people.
Um,
and now arriving also by train.
Uh,
and so this stuff is a riving in shuttle on Sham Banya or wherever,
you know,
this stuff gets dumped off at the dock and then it's the goes to this next stop,
uh,
on horse drawn wagons or on the backs of these people.
And so what,
what,
what burns found was,
was that,
uh,
in all of these day Patho mom,
that these images just inundate the place.
And this is modern political life.
This is this,
this is a really the emergence of modern political life.
So there are two things really interesting about Moodle and j in the end,
besides the Republica,
you know,
survives.
Ah,
you know,
the first really is that is I'll make this case hope clear,
hopefully clear in a minute.
It's the origins maybe of the modern,
right,
but it's also part of this or mass politics,
uh,
that,
that that happens.
And these are very rural,
uh,
date pop them all,
the [inaudible] again,
I'm sorry,
g e r s Zygiast,
the capital of which is oce,
which is wonderful cathedral,
uh,
is 83% rural at the time.
We're talking about.
Uh,
so these paddlers are going around to farm houses or people are coming to the
market and they're hearing the serves speakers along with the charlatans and,
and uh,
and jugglers a on a market day.
They're hearing people talk about no club ravage and Ah,
you know,
our brave general of Boulogne Jay and talking about how they hate Jews.
And so this merges with,
uh,
the antisemitism or markable thing about this department of the mom.
Uh,
now,
as I've said before,
I mean,
that's why I asked in the shot at all.
And now all those graves,
all those graves is that,
uh,
the antisemitic propaganda has a tremendous impact in the department of the
Marne,
which supports Moodle on Jay and the people who support,
I mean,
who,
who follow him.
And there were no Jews in the department of the mile.
So what,
what happens is the antisemites and this mass politics constructs the other,
the imagine other that literally it is not who did literally does not exist in
the Department of the Marne.
So it,
but it lodges in with the French would call the imaginary in,
in,
you know,
in the mental universe of mental world of ordinary people,
not all of them to be sure,
but it is this,
this sort of a on slot of images of boot on j uh,
that become part of this enormous,
uh,
propaganda campaign in France.
Uh,
they would print out balance and so political lists would already be printed out
and you pick your list.
I mean,
it's still a case.
I'm in this pool elections today,
at least where we are,
where we live,
it must be everywhere.
And how many millions of the ballots are printed there in 1889,
they would don't j posters,
5 million posters.
I mean,
that's a phenomenal amount.
7 million ballots and talking about mass politics photos,
they're no longer just dependent upon images that some clever person with,
with,
uh,
with crayons and pens have sketched.
It become these images of AP.
Now there are real photos of the guy on his horse.
And,
uh,
you,
you had to,
before you had to imagine Napoleon,
the,
like,
you had to imagine what the king look like,
or they'll,
Louie the 16th is identified with somebody who wants,
saw him from a distance.
When he tries to escape the Vrn,
somebody actually seen him and somebody else knew it was him because his nose
look the same as,
as,
as his face on a,
on a,
on a coin.
Uh,
but you didn't see people.
But here you could see,
you could see,
and Jay,
you could imagine when he looked like,
and even if you,
if you lived in the,
you know,
uh,
and the boss,
and,
and then the,
in appearance,
he,
and we live in the [inaudible] or the Ba,
a bus peer.
He ne you could imagine what else sauce look like.
Uh,
and it feeds into this kind of frenzy of,
of,
uh,
publications about Alsace.
Lorraine,
the most famous is called the,
the tour to false Bob [inaudible] phone.
Uh,
um,
and which to,
the brothers promise a their father on his deathbed that they will see France.
And there was the biggest selling book outside of the Bible in,
in,
in 19th century,
France.
Uh,
and they go around and in this very banal boring book and they see people all
wearing different costumes,
eating different things and doing different work,
but their hearts all pounding the same way.
And they're practically in tears on the state of collapse when they imagine
Alsace Loran and these,
these l station young women dress,
dress,
an Alsatian costumes and,
and thinking of the,
about a sauce and having to put up with the late Bush with,
with the Germans and all this stuff.
So,
uh,
but it,
so these,
the numbers are,
they just flood the countryside and these songs that people could sing in music
halls and a lot of the music calls in Paris,
there might've been a lot of minimal Moscow.
There was thinking anarchist songs,
uh,
in the 1890s,
but a lot of the other music halls are singing about general bu lone Jay and
songs like,
you know,
uh,
the big sweep that is with a broom sweeping away the corruption of these,
of these deputies,
of the Sean was a deputy.
And putting in your kind of big heroic guy.
And what about busts?
If you think about busts,
uh,
that is,
you know,
sculptured busts,
uh,
that this is the time when the image of the Republic,
my yon is,
I've said before,
is elbowing the Virgin Mary out of the way.
Uh,
and there's this sort of battle over space in classroom while on classroom walls
and in the streets of cities and villages and,
and all of that.
The mission crosses are being broken off in the middle of the night by their
enemies and said,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
And uh,
Merissa who no one was a great historian.
Uh,
one of the books that he did,
one of the many,
many,
many books that he did was on the images of the Republic in,
in,
uh,
in town halls.
You know,
in the Ma,
he where people get married and,
and,
and the,
the kinds of statutes that they put up in the third republic,
it comparable to the kind of work being done at warm memorials after a World War
One.
And,
and so Bruno Oj fits right into that because there's 100,000 bus of,
uh,
of brutal and Shea,
and you can,
uh,
you don't have to one,
they will give one to you to put it up.
Uh,
you know,
uh,
where you want and your dresser or whatever.
And so this is really mass politics.
Uh,
and,
uh,
he erodes,
um,
uh,
if he roads Republican support in some places he doesn't do well everywhere.
The republic is really stronger than its opponents.
That that's obviously one of the points in one of the departments that I
mentioned,
it doesn't matter which one it was the jails,
but he,
he,
uh,
builds upon strong support for a bona partism,
in that part of,
of,
of France.
Uh,
and of course,
one thing that he does is that he is able to,
uh,
he plays off beautifully,
with,
uh,
the,
the antisemites,
uh,
and their newspapers.
Uh,
a double mall is a newspaper called the Libra pothole.
the,
the free word or the,
the open word or,
uh,
is,
you know,
is sort of the classic of your land,
Right Wing newspaper and Charlotte Masa,
uh,
who was a monarchist and who it was a,
it was a subtle,
but he was a really great writer.
Mohas was just,
you know,
fantastic writer.
Uh,
he also is just a,
just vehemently antisemetic though it in,
in a lesson.
Well,
I mean,
antisemitism is,
Volvo are totally,
but,
but he,
he,
you more restrained in his creative criticism and et Cetera,
et cetera.
But this is,
fits right into the image of boot on j andJ is willing to,
uh,
to go along with this.
I mean,
who knows,
I've used antisemitic or not,
uh,
probably because of the long traditions of antisemitism in the army.
More about this later,
uh,
one imagines that,
that he was,
but this is what's important about it.
That,
and the fact that the first time these people are in the right is in the streets
and they're tough.
They're tough guys.
And,
and,
and this anticipates the 1920s and the 1930s also,
uh,
that and Paris has changed too.
I'm going to do a whole lecture on Paris one day,
but Paris is no longer,
uh,
the,
the Paris of,
of radical Republican a song,
Kudos of the artisans and the petty bourgeois who supported Maximilian
Robespierre in the French revolution.
That's no longer the Paris of 1848.
Uh,
the geographic shifts and social structure of Paris have,
have transformed and enhanced forth until 1968.
The big demonstrations,
they go money for demonstrations are those of the right for the canonization of
Joan of arc after,
after 1920,
uh,
against the Republican 1934.
So it's a different Paris.
But is,
is as my friend William Irvine has argued,
he was one of the first to argue this.
I think it is a turning point,
uh,
in the history of,
of the right as well.
Now to be sure you can't look through those wonderful glasses of hindsight.
And if you're trying to explain osh fits or you're trying to explain the arrest
of the Jews,
the Jewish children,
and their parents and grandparents in Paris,
and 42 and 43 by the French,
you know,
it's,
you,
it's a little much to go back and say,
you know,
it's,
he'd be on to filter the boot on Jay.
You know,
but that's the kind of connection that it's [inaudible] fault that that's the
kind of a connection that,
that hindsight gives you that,
that you have to be a little careful with.
But this stuff was out there.
Uh,
it was out there,
much war in Germany,
uh,
that was in France.
Uh,
but antisemitism was part of all of this.
And it was part of the whole image of,
uh,
of this man,
of this poor man who,
who,
uh,
had had enough and blows his brains all over his,
his mistresses,
mistress,
his grave.
Now,
um,
that's a long way of getting to,
uh,
the Dreyfus,
the Dreyfus affair.
And I'll say less about that because the Dreyfus affair is more obvious than,
uh,
than the Google Nj affair.
The Dreyfus affair,
uh,
reflects this anti Semitism that,
that to head bed accentuated by the economic crisis that begins in the mid,
uh,
1870s and 1873 and 1874 where it was easy to blame it on.
The Jews,
blame it on the Jewish bankers blaming it on the Jewish department stores a,
blame it on somebody.
Um,
and um,
but it fits a rather a nicely into all of that from the point of view of trying
to,
uh,
analyze,
um,
uh,
all of that now to them all.
Uh,
and his [inaudible].
Wow.
What's his name?
I never did say his first name.
Edward Edward [inaudible] Mall.
Uh,
his,
um,
newspaper La Liga,
her po hadn't been a very,
at the forefront of denouncing the scandals of the republic,
arguing that the scandals were inherent in a republic bites,
very form of his very existence.
And by the fact that is that Jews who dominate the dodge ball,
that is the wall of money controlled by the Rashi Lynn.
All of this,
the usual,
uh,
kind of,
of claims.
Um,
he had published a book in which he claimed that Jewish financiers were
conspiring to dominate France and that they indeed had done so.
Um,
and,
um,
he,
I,
he is at the forefront of this,
of,
of l'affaire.
And what the affair does is it pits,
uh,
basically,
um,
against it pits,
right against left it pits the French army and the Catholic Church and the
monarchists who are against Dreyfus.
It pits them against the Republicans against Socialists,
uh,
who supported Alfred Dreyfus.
Now he's worth a,
um,
he,
he's worth a minute.
In fact,
there's a very good book called love it.
And again,
my mind,
my former student,
Michael Burns called,
uh,
Dreyfus,
a family affair about the Dreyfus family,
not just about Dreyfus.
There've been probably 40 books are written about him,
but it's about his whole family.
And it's,
that's interesting in itself.
He was a sign of a,
an old Jewish family from El Sauce.
Uh,
his family had been paddlers and there were many Jewish peddlers,
uh,
in,
in eastern Europe,
particularly in Poland,
but in other places,
uh,
as well.
Uh,
his family,
uh,
became a textile manufacturers in the town of [inaudible] and they ended up in a
place,
a beautiful place called Rebo VA where the Ah,
that awesome.
It was a magnificent,
where the Vin,
the vineyards go right down to the,
uh,
right down to the,
the book.
Um,
and,
but they're assimilated and probably consider themselves French following 1871
for obvious reasons.
They move and they moved to Paris.
They moved to the 16th.
They're only small.
That is the fancy part of Paris.
Now again,
in the history of Jewish,
uh,
movement,
physical movement in France and from other places to France,
you have a growing gap between assimilated Jews with origins in,
in Germany or El Sas and other places who were more assimilated,
who come,
who have more money.
They're more free.
K,
they have more money.
They're not all wealthy,
but they see themselves as very assimilated and they live in the fancier
quarters.
And the,
the huge number of Jewish immigrants who arrived with virtually nothing from the
old Pale,
uh,
from where they were allowed to settle in the,
in the,
and the Russian empire.
And from Poland.
Poland had lost his independence in 1795 and wouldn't get it again until,
uh,
was a third partition.
It wouldn't get it again until 1918.
And they come to Paris carrying virtually nothing.
There's one story about these Jews who carried an empty suitcase and they said,
why are you carrying an empty suitcase when you're leaving Russia?
And they said,
because it's too shameful to have nothing to carry.
We want people to think that we have enough.
We have something.
And they had nothing.
And they get to Paris.
And some of the assembly that juice said,
hey,
we don't want those people here because they're going to fit into this
antisemitic propaganda of these characters.
The dirty Jew coming from Poland coming from Congress,
Poland coming from,
from Russia.
And they settle into my hay in Paris.
Uh,
uh,
and they work in the garment industry.
And some of them are anarchists and some of them are Marxists.
And,
and they were all extremely interesting people,
but Dreyfus and his family was extremely assimilated.
They were of some means.
And so they live in the fancy,
uh,
the fancy neighborhoods.
Um,
and I'm now in 1894.
I'll just tell the story very briefly,
uh,
for those who had,
haven't had time to read it yet,
evidence surfaced from a wastepaper basket,
uh,
in the office of a German military attache than somebody in the French army was
passing secret information to the Germans about French military operations on
the edge of a,
on the new frontier that is the voltage.
And,
and,
uh,
Alsace and Lorraine and circumstantial evidence pointed to a Captain Dreyfus,
and they confront him with the evidence.
It looks like his handwriting.
And when they do this,
this is very military gesture.
They gave him a present him with a pistol saying,
you too can blot your brains.
And in doing so,
admit your guilt.
And he was shocked.
He said,
well,
she's fuck who Bob.
I mean,
I didn't do this.
It's not me.
That's not me.
But that didn't matter,
uh,
to,
the army at all.
They convene him with,
and the writing did look like his writing too.
But then more things would come along to devastate the whole case.
Uh,
they can invoke a,
a secret,
a court martial and find him guilty of treason.
He was stripped of his rank in a ceremony at the academy.
Did he tear the big military school?
Uh,
and he sent a devil's island about what you have heard off the coast of South
America,
the northern coast,
a Hellhole,
yet more documents continued to be leaked.
Uh,
and,
uh,
the new chief of army intelligence,
a guy a called peacock.
The name doesn't matter what doesn't matter,
but you don't have to know what for this,
uh,
said that comes to the conclusion that it wasn't Dreyfus.
It couldn't have been him.
Uh,
the writings is not really the same.
Now,
[inaudible] was unlikely hero in all of this scenario because he wasn't
anti-semite.
He was a vicious anti-semite,
like almost everybody in the officer corps,
uh,
at the same time.
And He,
um,
comes to the conclusion that they were pen by another,
a Frenchman,
uh,
Esterhazy a Hungarian immigrant to second or third generation to,
to France,
a loss estimate,
a z.
Um,
but higher ranking officers get together and they say it's better to have this
Jew languishing in misery then to admit that we made a mistake.
And then along comes the right wing of the Catholic church,
particularly the assumptionist order,
which says the same thing.
He's a Jew,
thus he is guilty.
And so he is just,
you know,
he,
there he is not,
and nothing happens.
They send peacock off to a post in Tunisia as punishment for having discovered
the truth.
And the court,
uh,
puts a Esterhazy on trial and military court and he is acquitted.
Now at this point,
Zoloft,
it takes up the case.
He writes the famous article in a newspaper with the headline grow,
teach j'accuse he says,
[inaudible] the army.
I accused the government of covering all this up.
Uh,
the man is innocent.
And so the political right and the church hierarchy jump against Dreyfus and
socialists and the generally socialists and,
uh,
radical Republicans,
support,
um,
Dreyfus.
The newspaper of the assumptionist order demands that all Jews lose their
citizenship.
And Charlotte Rojas,
uh,
who I mentioned before,
an antisemitic novelist jumps into the fray a against them.
Um,
and soon,
uh,
some more documents were discovered.
Uh,
and it turns out that these,
uh,
they were added to Dreyfus is file long after he was languishing in deck on the
island and they're suddenly discovered by an ma man called Henri,
uh,
an officer and he'd forged them to make,
make it even clearer from those people wanting to believe that Dreyfus was
guilty,
that gr Dreyfus had,
had,
had done other bad things too.
And so they,
um,
uh,
a morass at one point solutes Henri for his patriotic forgery,
his patriotic forgery,
if that doesn't sound like some things in this country too,
I don't know what,
uh,
what does,
but anyway,
uh,
they finally,
oh,
he slit his throat in,
in the,
uh,
in the military,
a prison,
uh,
where he had been condemned for that,
for this forgery.
And they bring Dreyfus back from his island,
a broken man,
and they find him guilty.
Again,
a military court,
you're not talking about a civil court as a military court and they say he is
guilty,
but what extenuating circumstances?
Uh,
so,
uh,
finally,
and they send them back to Devil's island.
Uh,
finally he is pardoned in 1906,
um,
uh,
no,
he's,
he's pardoned actually before that in about 1900 east partner,
even 1880,
1899.
Um,
and,
but he's not fully exonerated until 1906,
but still,
this was another moment for the right as well,
particularly anti Republican,
right.
Because they had concluded that Dreyfus was guilty by the,
by the very fact that he was a Jew and it was better to have him in prison than
to suffer the blow,
uh,
of,
the army,
uh,
having,
been caught up in,
in its own snare and a,
I get,
and he retreated to his own society.
Devi,
Kimonti,
you know,
his own his own life.
Uh,
you know,
uh,
amazingly enough,
forgiven,
forgiving for all what had happened.
And again,
I said this earlier,
but it's simply end with this,
that one of the ironies of all of this and helps us make the point of what
happens to the right and antisemitism in France and in Europe,
is that his granddaughter dies in the death camp of Auschwitz.
I have a good week.
See you on Monday.